Welcome back everyone this is my guardians of
the galaxy i am groot trailer for the new series
that's premiering august 10th there's a bunch of
easter eggs here i'll explain where it fits in the
timeline what's going on how it connects with all
the other guardians of the galaxy stuff coming up
like guardians of the galaxy three if you're brand
new to the channel i will be doing videos for the
episodes be sure to subscribe to get everything
they're gonna be dropping all the episodes on
august 10th because it's basically like a series
of five shorts so i think it's going to amount to
like a full hour of content between all the five
shorts and it'll be sort of like the appetizer
to she-hulk episode one which will be dropping
the week after that on august 17th she-hulk is
gonna be nine episodes though that'll be like
a regular series i am groot is like a series of
shorts just to be clear but as you can tell it's
all centered around baby groot it's not teenage
group the current version of the character so it
takes place a little bit earlier in the timeline
marvel confirmed that it's meant to take place
between the end of guardians of the galaxy 2 after
they've defeated ego the living planet in the
sovereign but before the post-credits scene at the
very end where they reveal he's grown into teenage
group he's cussing at star-lord playing the video
game just trashing his room and as you can see
some of this is meant to take place on the ravager
ship the eclector so apparently that ship is still
around after yondu blew it up during their escape
like you see it a little bit during the series
of post credit scenes where they're on it so they
escape yondu blows up part of it and then they
just apparently repair it after the fact but like
i just did a video for the guardians of the galaxy
3 trailer that they released at comic con they
didn't release it publicly so i'll link it below
in the description so you can learn what happened
during that but in the guardians of the galaxy
3 trailer like after the events of thor love and
thunder in the guardians of the galaxy holiday
special the younger 2014 gamora is revealed to
have become the new leader of the ravagers since
the end of avengers end game it looks like a
slightly upgraded version of a collector that they
took with them in guardians of the galaxy too they
did confirm that vin diesel came back to do the
voice of baby groot for all the episodes the way
they do his voice for baby groot though is that
he just does it normally and then they modulate
it so that it sounds like a baby speaking but
it's still vin diesel's they also confirmed
that bradley cooper came to do the voice of rocket
during the series so rocket is going to be part of
the series i'm assuming that not all the guardians
will be on it just because it's a bunch of shorts
and it's mostly about groot's adventures separate
from the guardians like it's running around
getting into trouble like baby's day out style
but it's groot in a bunch of different episodes at
least in most of the episodes that's kind of what
it seems like is going on like he's by himself
just getting into all kinds of trouble i love the
way they open the trailer too like making it sound
like a really huge thing obviously because groot
is so tiny and the characters that he sees at the
beginning of the trailer are even tinier but they
open the trailer with him on this foreign planet
meeting this new race of characters that all treat
him sort of like a gulliver's travels kind of way
where he's this interloper and they think that
he's this big threat and it's just meant to be
this big funny moment with them marshalling all
these forces like all these jet packs all these
weapons to try and kill him and it barely even
scratches him like he's afraid of hurting them
and afraid of getting hurt but they can barely
even scratch him and then it turns out that they
all just want some food so they just all start
eating from the leaf and everybody's happy they
make a joke about how he's a hero of few words
because he literally only says i am groot the way
that james gonna explain it though and they kind
of explain this in the comics is that he's part
of the race called flora colossus and they do have
their own language that they speak to each other
so when he's talking to rocket the other guardians
of the galaxy characters other marvel characters
he is speaking a bunch of different types of
sentences a bunch of different words it just comes
out of his mouth as i am groot so it's not like
root is trying to say i am groot over and over and
over again it just sounds that way coming out of
his mouth he's actually speaking regular sentences
it looks like some of the episodes will take
place on this planet because you see groot
having a couple different adventures doing a
couple different things while the guardians of
the galaxy ship is parked there you see groot get
himself into all kinds of trouble across a couple
different types of scenes him with the feather
boa him on the spaceship wearing the christmas
tree pajamas like they actually have tiny little
pajamas that they give to him made up to look like
christmas trees because he is literally a tree
i think what's going on here where he's dancing
with this other version of groot is this is in
an episode where he takes a bath like this just
looks like a water creation this episode on that
foreign planet where you see him wearing a bunch
of different types of clothes using his own body
in the leaves to create the clothes i think is
meant to be from the same episode specifically
just because it's him creating a bunch of
different clothes from himself literally episode
one is titled magnum opus and it says inside the
collector's quadrant baby group gathers various
items to draw the guardians of the galaxy later
causing an explosion inside one of the ship's
rooms you see him causing an explosion here in
the trailer it seems like it's from that episode
rocket finds baby groot trying to fix a blown-up
hole and receives the drawing another explosion
causes rocket to be almost sucked out of the ship
only to be saved by baby groot sounds like bradley
cooper is going to be in a lot of that episode
episode 2 is titled groot takes a bath where
it seems like a lot of this footage comes from
taking a bath allows groot to create a variety
of costumes out of his leaves like i said here
angering a nearby animal then there's three more
shorts right after that but they're all releasing
them together so like you watch them back to back
so it's almost like just watching an hour-long
single episode with a bunch of different parts
there's a bunch of different footage of him on the
guardians of the galaxy ship interacting with a
bonsai tree trying to feed it some fruit so like i
said this is meant to take place before the events
of that guardians of the galaxy 2 post credits
scene where he's grown into teenage groot and
just to explain their timeline so far in the mcu
because we just got the guardians of the galaxy
3 trailer with the oldest version of groot that
we've seen so far in that post-credits scene he
grew to teenage group then mostly stayed the same
age through the events of avengers infinity war
which was just like a very short time jump later
like it was less than a year later he was snapped
so he didn't age at all when avengers end game
in the final battle picked up and he was only
a little bit older during the events of thor
11 thunder which took place like a couple years
after the end of avengers end game he seemed a
tiny bit older and a little bit more mature but
he's still very much teenage young version of
groot then during the guardians of the galaxy 3
trailer at comic-con which i just did a video for
he seemingly had his own version of a hulk out
moment like we saw in the first guardians of the
galaxy movie where he grew to full adult groot
size like at the end of the first guardians film
where he hulks out and all of his parts grow super
huge it seems like in the guardians of the galaxy
3 movie that'll be the moment where he grows into
full alpha groot size vin diesel called him alpha
groot during the movie like the most version of
groot so i think they've been saving him growing
back to full size for like that big moment either
to be like groot smash or we are smash is in this
moment where he and peter quill are fighting
back to back peter quill is wearing his comic
book accurate ravager's uniform notice they have
the chest symbols in the first movie so they have
the same chest symbols and they're treating
these classic comic book uniforms like the new
blue ravagers uniforms but they're based on the
original comic book versions from annihilation
conquest and that was the comic book run where
this current version of the guardians roster
came together but james gunn kind of changed
the plot of how they actually came together
also adam warlock fought with the team
during annihilation conquest that period
at his back groot is fighting a bunch of people
but because he doesn't use traditional blasters or
weapons the same way he just grows his body parts
to fight people he has a kind of groot version of
a hulk out where he gets super huge it even zooms
on his face and it seems like his face is getting
bigger and getting more mature just growing bigger
in general even after the first guardians of the
galaxy movie we were kind of waiting for this tiny
baby version of crew to grow to full-sized groot
because in the comics the way they explained is
a little bit different in the comics he has the
ability to regrow his entire body from like a
single twig so for instance in the guardians of
the galaxy comic he gets blown up rocket puts
like a single groot splinter in a potted plant
and it eventually regrows groot back to what he
used to be but the way that james gunn explained
this new version of groot that we've been seeing
in the last couple of movies is that this groot at
the end of the first guardians of the galaxy
movie who sacrifices himself is dead like he
didn't come back the baby version of groot is like
the offspring of this version of groot and during
avengers end game james gunn actually revealed
what he was saying when groot was getting snapped
here like you see him slowly disappearing he
said during this scene groot is crying out
father to rocket as rocket is sort of freaking
out watching everybody disappear around him
so teenage groot here this version of groot really
does think of rocket as his father which is why a
lot of people are theorizing that because so much
of the guardians of the galaxy 3 story is about
rockets bad dads so to speak the high evolutionary
and it deals with a lot of his origin story
that rocket will be the one to sacrifice himself
for the rest of the team during the movie james
gunn did say that it would be the last marvel
movie with this roster of the guardians of the
galaxy so like some people will die off so post
all your theories about who that's going to be
the other real big thing that's happening that
they didn't release a trailer for later this year
is going to be the guardians of the galaxy holiday
special and james gunn did say that that would be
like a prequel to guardians of the galaxy three
it'll be live action it's inspired as you guessed
by the star wars holiday special but with the
guardians of the galaxy characters it'll be live
action it'll be treated as canon and it'll sort
of explain what's happening with the team after
they left thor in thor love and thunder but before
the events of guardians of the galaxy iii because
they're releasing all the i am groot shorts on the
same day and they're all meant to be relatively
short i'll probably just do easter eggs for the
entire series in a single video but we will get
some more she-hulk trailers in the next couple of
weeks and obviously i'll be doing videos for all
the she-hulk episodes too there's a bunch of other
stuff happening there were a bunch of other big
comic-con announcements that i still haven't had
time to do videos for so if you have any special
requests just write them below in the comments
everyone click here for my guardians of the galaxy
3 trailer video in easter eggs and click here for
my brand new black panther wakanda forever trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!